.
>> THANK YOU ALL VERY, VERY MUCH
FOR THAT.
>>> WE HAVE A CNN EXCLUSIVE
RIGHT NOW HERE IN "THE SITUATION
ROOM."
OUR CHIEF INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT CLARISSA WARD GOT
SOME EXCLUSIVE ACCESS TO A CITY
IN AFGHANISTAN THAT'S CONSIDERED
TO BE THE BIRTHPLACE OF THE
TALIBAN.
IT IS NOW ONE OF THEIR BIGGEST
TARGETS AS U.S. TROOPS WITHDRAW
FROM THE COUNTRY.
CLARISSA IS JOINING US LIVE
TONIGHT FROM KABUL.
THE TALIBAN OFFENSIVE IS CLEARLY
INTENSIFYING.
YOU'RE DOING AMAZING REPORTING.
UPDATE OUR VIEWERS.
>> Reporter: SO, WOLF, IF YOU
CAN BELIEVE IT, NOW, NEARLY HALF
OF AFGHANISTAN'S 34 PROVINCIAL
CAPITALS ARE UNDER DIRECT THREAT
FROM THE TALIBAN.
THREE OF THEM ARE UNDER SIEGE.
AND WE VISITED ONE OF THOSE
KANDAHAR, IT'S A STRATEGICALLY
VITAL CITY FOR THE GOVERNMENT.
IT'S ALSO THE SPIRITUAL
BIRTHPLACE OF THE TALIBAN.
IMPORTANT FOR BOTH SIDES UNDER
SIEGE.
THE SITUATION THERE IS
DESPERATE.
TAKE A LOOK.
ON THE ROAD TO KANDAHAR'S FRONT
LINE, THERE IS STILL CIVILIAN
TRAFFIC, EVEN AS THE TALIBAN
INCHES DEEPER INTO THE CITY.
AFGHAN COMMANDOS HAVE AGREED TO
TAKE US TO ONE OF THEIR BASES.
THIS USED TO BE A WEDDING HALL.
NOW IT'S THE FRONT LINE
POSITION.
MOST OF THE FIGHTING HERE
HAPPENS AT NIGHT.
BUT TALIBAN SNIPERS ARE AT WORK
24 HOURS A DAY.
FROM SNIPERS?
>> YES.
>> THE MEN TELL US THE TALIBAN
ARE HIDING IN HOUSES JUST 50
YARDS AWAY FROM US.
AND THEY SHOOT FROM PEOPLE'S
HOMES?
>> YES.
YOU SEE THESE ARE CIVILIANS'
HOMES.
WE CANNOT USE BIG WEAPONS, THE
HEAVY WEAPONS.
>> Reporter: UP ON THE ROOF,
THIS MAJOR WANTS TO SHOW US
SOMETHING.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE THE TALIBAN
FLAG JUST OVER ON THE MOUNTAIN
TOP THERE.
>> IT'S BEEN NEARLY A MONTH
SINCE THE TALIBAN PENETRATED THE
CITY.
SINCE THEN, THESE MEN HAVEN'T
HAD A BREAK.
U.S. AIR STRIKES ONLY COME IN AN
EMERGENCY.
THE REST OF THE TIME, IT'S UP TO
THEM TO HOLD THE LINE.
>> WE FEEL A LITTLE BIT WEAK OUT
U.S. AIR STRIKES AND GROUND
SUPPORT AND EQUIPMENT, HE SAYS.
BUT THIS IS OUR SOIL, AND WE
HAVE TO DEFEND IT.
>> Reporter: IN A VILLA IN THE
EASTERN PART OF THE CITY, THIS
LAWMAKER IS HUNKERED DOWN.
IN DECADES OF WAR, HE SAYS HE'S
NEVER SEEN THE FIGHTING THIS
BAD.
>> MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN THIS
CITY ARE WAITING FOR WHEN THEY
WILL BE KILLED, WHEN SOMEONE
WILL KILL THEM, WHEN THEIR HOME
WILL BE DESTROYED.
AND IT IS HAPPENING EVERY
MINUTE.
>> Reporter: JUST SPELL OUT FOR
ME HERE.
THE TALIBAN IS BASICALLY
SURROUNDING THE ENTIRE CITY NOW;
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> DEFINITELY, YES.
>> Reporter: AND, SO, WHERE IS
THERE TO GO?
>> NOWHERE.
SO THERE IS ONLY TWO OPTIONS: DO
OR DIE.
>> Reporter: DO OR DIE?
AND WHAT DOES "DO" LOOK LIKE?
>> THAT IS THE THING TO CONVINCE
DIFFERENT SITES TO CEASE FIRE,
TO WORK ON PEACE, TO CONVINCE
THEM TO NOT FIGHT AGAIN.
>> Reporter: BUT THAT IS A TALL
ORDER IN A CITY WHERE WAR HAS
BECOME PART OF EVERY DAY LIFE.
YOU CAN PROBABLY SEE THERE IS A
LOT MORE CARS ON THE ROAD THAN
THERE WERE PREVIOUSLY, AND
THAT'S BECAUSE IN JUST TWO
MINUTES AT 6:00 P.M., THE CELL
PHONE NETWORK GETS CUT ACROSS
THE CITY, AND THAT'S WHEN THE
FIGHTING USUALLY STARTS.
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT, THE SOUNDS
OF GUNFIRE AND ARTILLERY PIERCE
THE DARKNESS.
THEY ARE INTENT ON TAKING IT
BACK, AND THE GOVERNMENT KNOWS
IT CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE IT.
BY DAY AN EERIE CALM HOLDS.
THE UN SAYS MORE THAN 10,000
PEOPLE ARE NOW DISPLACED IN THIS
CITY.
ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF TOWN, WE
FIND 30 FAMILIES CAMPED OUT IN
AN ABANDONED CONSTRUCTION SITE.
HE'S SAYING THAT NONE OF THESE
CHILDREN HAVE FATHERS.
ALL OF THEIR FATHERS HAVE BEEN
KILLED IN THE FIGHTING.
THIS 35-YEAR-OLD FLED WITH HER
TWO CHILDREN AFTER HER HUSBAND
WAS SHOT DEAD.
BUT STILL IT GETS CLOSER AND
CLOSER.
LAST NIGHT I DIDN'T SLEEP ALL
NIGHT, SHE SAYS.
AND THE FEAR WAS IN MY HEART.
IN THE SHORT TIME WE ARE THERE,
MORE FAMILIES ARRIVE.
STREET VENDOR SAYS THEY FLED THE
VILLAGE OF AN AIR STRIKE HIT.
THREE DEAD BODIES WERE ROTTING
OUTSIDE OUR HOMES FOR DAYS, BUT
IT WAS TOO DANGEROUS TO GET
THEM.
THE TALIBAN IS ATTACKING ON ONE
SIDE.
THE GOVERNMENT IS ATTACKING THE
OTHER.
IN THE MIDDLE, WE ARE JUST
LOSING.
BACK AT THE HOUSE, DUST COATS
THE CHAIRS WHERE WEDDING GIFTS
WOULD NORMALLY SIT.
AS THE SIEGE OF KAND HAR
CONTINUES, LIFE HERE IS IN LIMBO
WITH NO END IN SIGHT.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE,
WOLF, OF THE UPTICK IN VIOLENCE,
THE RED CROSS SAYS THE HOSPITAL
THEY SUPPORT IN KAND HAR HAS
TREATED MORE THAN 2,300 WEAPON
WOUNDED PATIENTS IN THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS OF THIS YEAR.
THAT IS MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT THAT THEY SAW IN THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS OF LAST YEAR.
ALL OF THIS HAPPENING AGAINST
THE BACKDROP OF THE U.S.
WITHDRAWAL, WOLF, AND THE NEW UN
ENVOY TO AFGHANISTAN, WARNING
TODAY THAT THIS SITUATION COULD
POTENTIALLY, QUOTE, A
CATASTROPHE SO SERIOUS, IT WOULD
HAVE FEW, IF ANY, PARALLELS THIS
CENTURY.
WOLF?
>> WHAT ABOUT YOU?
I'M WORRIED ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON THERE, OBVIOUSLY.
HOW DANGEROUS IS IT?
>> THE SITUATION IS VERY
DANGEROUS.
PRIMARILY IT IS DANGEROUS FOR
THE AFGHAN PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE LIVED THROUGH DECADES
AND DECADES OF HOW AND NOW THERE
IS PROFOUND CONCERN AND ANXIETY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY ABOUT
WHAT THE FUTURE WILL HOLD.
WILL THIS TURN INTO A PROTECTED
CIVIL WAR?
WILL THINGS GET EVEN UGLIER?
HOW CAN AFGHAN FORCES LAUNCH A
COUNTER OFFENSIVE TO TAKE BACK
THE TERRITORY, TO STOP THE
TALIBAN FROM SEIZING MORE WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
THE U.S. MILITARY.
YOU HEARD THEM SAY IT.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
THEIR DUTY AND THAT THEY MUST
DEFEND THEIR SOIL AS YOU HEARD
THERE.
BUT THERE IS STILL A BIG
QUESTION MARK AS TO HOW THEY CAN
DO THAT WHEN THEY'RE PUTTING OUT
FIRES ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THE FIRST CAPITAL FOLLOWING
TODAY TO T